amy is with us in uh flint michigan hi
amy how can we help
hi dave hi rachel hey how are you
good how are you good how can we help
so i had in the spring actually right
when coveted hit i had an issue with
mold in my house
um i have since got it fixed
insurance covered it and everything but
i
have been diagnosed with mold toxicity
so unfortunately i am working from home
and have been since about march um and i
got a permanent position at home now
i have now found another mold spot in my
house
that has to be taken care of so i'm not
really sure how to go about it
you know my insurance mold coverage is
maxed out
so do i take out a loan
to take care of all the mold because my
health comes first
i mean i they're talking maybe up to ten
thousand dollars worth of damage
and i'm just not sure exactly how to go
about it because i
you know i'm trying to follow your plan
i know that you know i don't want to be
slave to the lender i don't want to take
out another loan
but i know that my health comes first so
i'm not really sure how to go about it
are you single i am
what's your household income
it's about 36. and you obviously own
this home
yeah i have two roommates
what's the house worth
um probably
about 130ish to 140.
and what do you owe on it
about 110.
[Music]
so a ten thousand dollar loan when you
make thirty six thousand dollars a year
is what's known as a
lot of money
yeah okay
well i i don't put your health in
jeopardy and i don't
know enough about you being diagnosed
with mold toxicity as far as i
understood we all have mold toxicity
um so it's new to me that some people
haven't some don't i
don't know i'm not being smart like i
just don't know i know it's not good for
anybody
uh is my point and so if you've got a
special
uh level of sensitivity to it which is i
suspect what you're saying
um then obviously it escalates the
situation
i've been doing this show 30 years and
i've been put
personally in a whole bunch of corners
where
the it looked like the only way i was
borrowing money but i a long time ago
gave up the idea of borrowing money so i
can't recommend you borrow money so i
have to recommend something else
because i wouldn't do it myself and i
especially wouldn't do it if i made
thirty six thousand dollars a year and
one borrow ten thousand dollars for the
second go around the mold on the same
stinking house
i'd sell this house and move
this is gonna come up again what are you
going to do next time it's ten thousand
dollars
i mean this house has got a mold problem
or for some reason it's got a
susceptibility
to a new area of the house amy like why
didn't they fix it in the first place
yeah
yeah this is a whole new area that's
what i would say i would say you didn't
fix it
well the insurance maxed out but you
didn't fix the problem i had mold in my
house
and now i still have mold in my house so
like that's on them they
they need to fix it in my opinion
yeah i know but they had a they had a
certain amount they were
the insurance company had a cap your
homeowner's mold coverage only
went up to a certain amount yeah but
that they needed to explain that to her
then to say we can only fix x amount
it's like they didn't even find the
other stuff
well she knew she might you knew you
maxed out your insurance on the first
repair right
yeah and i didn't find this new spot
until
um just last week yeah but and the point
is though that it's
uh if ten thousand dollars is correct
that was a pretty substantial miss
rachel's saying by the mold people
i mean if there's a ten thousand dollars
worth of mold damage and you finished
work
just a few months ago they missed
something
right it had to already be there yeah
this one was kind of hidden in the attic
and i don't know if they really did
enough checking in the attic before yeah
yeah they missed it
so um you know i don't know
what it means to your health if you can
afford to live there for a little while
without damaging your health i don't
know that i don't know how to explain
that
i know that dave and sharon ramsey had a
lot of different things come up
that felt like they were impossible
situations and we were put in a corner
where we had to make
horrible choices but to avoid debt and
never going back again we made those
choices and now 20 years later
we're extremely prosperous because we
made those choices well and what it does
amy when you
kind of make that line in the sand and
you just say no matter what we're not
borrowing money
that forces you to see other options yep
and then you get creative and then you
say you know what maybe i will just sell
the house
or maybe i'm going to get out and have
the roommates help i mean you start to
actually look at different options
versus just yielding to debt
when you have that stance and so the
fact that you're a little bit
you're kind of wish you washed a little
bit in your questions and maybe your
career maybe you got to work on your
career because you don't make any money
and you know you got to work on maybe
you're going to be working outside the
home
uh to make more money and um
that'd be okay too uh because you're you
know
average household income is 59 000 in
america and i'm not picking on you i'm
not shaming you for what you're making
i'm just saying that long term uh
five years from now what are you going
to be doing that makes eighty thousand
dollars a year instead of thirty six
and you need to be aiming at that and
that might be part of the fix for this
ten thousand dollar problem
it might be the extra job that you take
on and you go make ten thousand dollars
in a couple of months
and uh you work your tail end off over
the next three months and you make ten
thousand bucks
and you pay cash for this fix that's
okay with me if you wanna do that
uh if you can survive your health for
three for those three months i don't
i don't know how sensitive this
situation is but if it's super sensitive
to where you're going to be seriously
ill in the next 30 days out of the house
then you need to move and you need to
put the house up for sale
and you need to not try to fix a moldy
house all the time let's just move on